so today we're going to talk about
hyperbolic geometry it's a different
kind of geometry than what you're used
to we all grew up with Euclidean
geometry and we're going to talk a
little bit about the space then we're
going to talk about what it is to live
in the space so we get a sort of
visceral understanding of it
particularly when you talk about what
it's like to play a baseball golf or
other sports in hyperbolic space there's
lots of ways to sort of make a model for
it so one is it's based on it's just the
inside of the unit disc is the set of
points which are within distance one of
the origin a Euclidean distance one but
now I'm going to define a very different
way of measuring distances between two
points and this is going to have the
property for instance that if you want
to travel along us through the shortest
path in hyperbolic space you travel
along these semi circles which are
perpendicular to the boundary that's one
property it has and another property it
has is that you start at the origin and
you walk straight out to the boundary
that's going to take you an infinite
amount of time as long as you keep
walking at the same speed it's an
infinite distance away yeah so this this
boundary isn't really there which is why
I tried to draw it sort of in a dotted
way so these lines are straight from the
hyperbolic viewpoint which means that if
I want if I'm standing here at say
position a and I want to get over here
into position B this is the fastest way
to do so in hyperbolic space that takes
the least time what happens if I were to
go here and cut my way from here to hit
that's not that would be longer I would
take longer it's sort of like in here if
I were to start here at position a and I
wanted to get to position B in Euclidean
space and I were to do that that would
get there but it would take me take me
somewhat longer and let me show you just
a couple facts that are true in
hyperbolic space and we'll use them and
see how they play out when we start
trying to do sports in hyperbolic space
so one of them if I draw sort of here
I'm in hyperbolic space and I have a
ball of radius R ball of radius R in
hyperbolic space what is its area so
this is 2 pi
Kochhar minus 2 pi most people aren't
familiar with that but that's roughly pi
times e to the
now he is a number which is roughly 2.7
TR so that means every time you increase
you increase your radius by one you
multiply your area by about 2.7 so we
all know that if you start doubling and
you double over and over you grow faster
and faster this is how compound interest
works and if you look at the
circumference or what's the length of
the circle some mathematicians would
call a circumference that turns out to
be equal to 2 pi hyperbolic sine times R
and again that's roughly pi e to the R
so the length of the boundary grows just
as fast as the area does now let's let's
compare that to Euclidean space so that
remember the area of Euclidean ball of
radius R was PI R squared and the
circumference in Euclidean space or the
length of the circle Euclidean space is
2 PI R so this grows quadratically this
grows linear and here both area and
circumference grow exponentially at the
same rate okay let's think about what
happens in you in baseball
so in baseball we'll idealize this a
little bit so we're going to have a
field it's going to quote made up of a
quadrant and the infield has radius 100
and the outfield has radius 300 and so
if you look at this guy the area of this
outfield is just over 6 is just over
60,000 if I remember right it's about
63,000 okay
and so in American baseball we have
three outfielders out here and they are
able to cover most of the outfield and
so we can imagine that an outfielder can
cover about 20,000 square feet well what
would happen in hyperbolic baseball if
you took the same picture well now the
area of the outfield would be it's 1/4
the area of the area of the ball of
radius 300 minus 1/4 of the area of the
ball of radius 100 and that's much
bigger than 10 to the 99
ginormous so how many outfielders do we
need well each of them can cover 20
thousand square feet which is sort of a
dubious assumption you need more than 10
to the 99 over 20,000 outfielders which
is bigger than 10 to the 94 so one thing
you can see here is you're not going to
make any Disney movies about having a
family big enough to have an entire
baseball team that's not going to work I
move to the next next sport we'll talk
about golf so imagine you just you're a
golfer here stick to stick to
mathematics mess up anyway so suppose
you know you're standing here and you
your flag is over here 300 feet away
have a nice little wedge in to the hole
and you hit a very good shot it's one
degree off but it's exactly 300 feet how
would you estimate that in Euclidean
space you'd say well that's going to be
roughly 1 degrees worth of a circle of
radius 300 the circle of radius 300 has
length 2 pi times 300 and then you take
one eight one degree worth of that
that's one 360th that turns out to be if
I remember right something that like
about five point two three so you're
about five point two three feet from the
hole looks pretty good you should be
able to put a lot well you should but I
don't always do so now what would happen
if you did the same thing in hyperbolic
space now you're 300 feet here's your
pen you're one degree off you hit it
exactly 300 feet you're feeling pretty
good
so we suppose we make that same estimate
well what's the size of a circumference
of a circle of radius 300 well that was
2 pi Sencha 300 which remembers like PI
e the 300 and now we're going to bye-bye
360 well that's bigger than 10 to the
100 so this estimate suggests you're
you're some number of feet which has
over a hundred digits away from the hole
okay so this can't be accurate because
you know that you started 300 feet from
the hole and you hit it 300 feet so
you're most 600 feet from the hole so we
learned that this is not a very good
thing to do and not providing a very
good estimate so and while is in
Euclidian space walking around the
circle isn't so very inefficient in the
hyperbolic space that's going to be a
very inefficient way to get around so
how far are we from the pin then so you
can do a little bit of hyperbolic
trigonometry and it turns out you're
more than 590 feet from the pin which is
almost as bad as turning around hitting
it backwards so hey I was what happened
it curved away what did the ball do one
way of thinking about this is what does
this look like it you can you're suppose
you start at the origin you travel 300
hyperbolic feet towards the boundary and
then you're one degree off and you
travel 300 hyperbolic feet towards the
boundary it turns out that the shortest
way to get there goes all the way way
back in and comes back out
okay so let's let me say my second shot
my next shot is going to have to follow
a curve that's so sharp it's another big
way right so you know you're likely you
could now you're 590 feet now you're
likely to be 1180 feet away after your
next shot even if it's very good et
cetera so you're probably never going to
get there tomorrow you clearly in eyes I
thought oh wow I'm really close to the
pin now this is easy but in fact that
puff isn't open to me like well it is
but this turns out to be distance 10 to
the 100 and if you want a path that is
distance 590 it does something more like
that it goes back in towards the center
and comes back out
the outfielders if you actually were
somehow they got the ball across the
plate and you despite not seeing until
with six feet from you managed to hit it
then the outfielders wouldn't see it
till it was six or seven feet from them
so their only strategy would be to stand
there with their mitts open